>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
[ Silence ]
>> MaryAnn Sonntag: Now I
have the honor and pleasure
of introducing you to a
well known illustrator
and author, Melissa Sweet.
Melissa is herself some
writer and some illustrator.
Pardon me for taking liberty with
the title of her latest book,
Some Writer!: The Story
of E.B. White.
Okay. Melissa has illustrated
nearly 100 children's books ranging
from board books to
non-fiction titles.
Born and raised in New
Jersey, Melissa graduated
from Endicott College and the
Kansas City Institute of Art.
Her artwork has appeared not only
in books but in The New York Times,
Martha Stewart Living, Madison
Park Greetings, and Smilebox.
Melissa has received many
honors for her illustrating
and writing including two
Caldecott honors, a Sibert medal,
the Orbis Pictus Award,
the Stieglitz Strauss award
and the Cook [phonetic] prize.
That's a lot of honors,
don't you think.
[Clapping] Yes.
Reviewers have described her
unique mixed media illustrations
as creative delights
and I would agree.
From her first job illustrating
the Pinky and Rex series
to her latest adventure in authoring
and illustrating the life story
of E.B. White, Melissa Sweet brings
to her readers breathtaking art,
well researched and
designed non-fiction,
and now the masterpiece biography
of E.B. White written for pre-teens
but I'm 66 years old and think
this wonderful book will appeal
to readers of all ages.
I now present to you, Melissa Sweet.
[ Clapping ]
[ Silence ]
>> Melissa Sweet: Good morning.
Thank you for that
lovely introduction.
They've made me above
these microphones.
I feel better.
It's good.
So salutations are in order.
Thank you.
I'm thrilled to be here and to
introduce my new book, Some Writer!
but first let's take a listen
to E.B. White reading
from Charlotte's Web.
[ Silence ]
Ah.
I think our sound -- well our
sound isn't -- is -- that's okay.
Maybe we can hear it at the end.
I had a beautiful audio
of E.B. White.
I don't know if any of you know that
E.B. White did the audio version
of Charlotte's Web a number of years
ago along with Trumpet of the Swan.
And so I listened to that for about
three years nonstop while I was
researching this book.
So young scholars as Stuart
Little often called his students,
often ask me where ideas come from.
And the idea for this book
came innocently enough.
I was walking my dogs as I do every
day and sometimes ideas come easy
and sometimes you have
to go after them.
This one just popped
into my head one day
as I was looking for
next my biography.
I wanted to do another biography.
I had done a few and I love
the research part of it.
Life is always a rich and
steady time when you're waiting
for something to happen or
to hatch, E.B. White said.
And one of the things I discovered
in researching this biography was
how much E.B. White loved eggs.
Eggs of all kinds.
So the book begins
and opens with eggs.
He wrote a chicken primer and of
course, Charlotte lays the eggs
in the doorway of the barn
which was the inspiration
of -- for Charlotte's Web.
Immediately, questions came
up that had to be answered.
I wanted to know how did he come up
with the idea for Charlotte's Web?
How many drafts did it
take him to write the book?
And living in Maine, I
knew that he loved Maine.
How young was he when he
finally -- when he -- sorry.
First came to Maine?
And most importantly, what were
the names of all of his dogs?
So some of the dogs -- some of his
dogs have the same name as my dogs.
We were totally different
kinds of kids but there --
we had a few things in common.
When E.B. White was older,
someone asked him what dime novels
he read when he was growing up?
And he said, never
read a dime novel.
I spent my youth on a
bicycle and in trees.
We had that in common.
I spent my youth on
a bicycle with dogs.
I loved to go to the library but I
was not a particularly great reader.
Doesn't mean I didn't like books
but I didn't love reading as much
as I did making art and playing
with these kids that you see.
Who here had spirographs
and Etch-A-Sketches?
Yes me too.
So paint by numbers and color
forms and all those things --
these things that looks like
toys are really wonderful
design teachers.
So I was learning to make design.
I was kind of preparing
myself to be an artist.
Anybody here grow up in the
New York metropolitan area
and have John Gnagy for -- a few
hands up there who taught us how
to draw on Saturday mornings.
And of course, I go to
my studio all the time.
More preparation.
The artist Teresita
Fernandez said that --
says that making art is a
solitary process and it is.
So every day I go to my studio
just the way people go to work.
Kids go to school.
I go to my studio.
Early on in my career, I read that
Joyce Carol Oates said that she went
to her -- she wrote for 4
hours a day and I thought
if it's good enough for Joyce
Carol that's good enough for me.
So my studio is part library,
part kindergarten classroom.
I have everything I need
to work there all day long
and I do work probably
more than four hours.
My materials are very simple.
I don't do any of my
art on computer.
It's all by hand and it's typical
watercolor gwash [phonetic]
found objects.
So I'm either writing a book
or I'm illustrating a book
or I might be researching a book but
whatever I'm doing so as long as I'm
in my studio, I feel
that I'm working.
So we'll move on from here.
How do begin a biography of one
of America's most beloved writers?
Well, I went back home after I had
that idea, about five minutes later.
And I began -- I took the book
Letters of E.B. White off the shelf
and I began reading
everything he wrote.
I went to Cornell where
he went to school.
I actually saw his farm in Maine
although it's not a public place.
The family brought me
there and of course,
you could see the title
on this book.
This book is revised and
edited by Martha White.
Martha White is a neighbor and
friend of mine in Rockport, Maine.
And she was generous enough to
talk with me fairly early on.
I had done quite a bit of work
before I talked to her but that's --
we'll talk more about that.
And I had some preparation
with biographies.
I had illustrated The Right
Word which is about Peter Roget,
the man who invented the thesaurus.
He was a list maker as a kid.
So in any biography, who are
these people as children?
Was anything ever hard for them?
What was -- what were their
defining moments that led them
to become the person they became?
I wrote and illustrated
the Balloons Over Broadway.
The story of Marionette maker,
Tony Sarg who invented the
Macy's Parade balloons.
And Horace Pippin who was a
self taught artist and he --
as a soldier in the war lost the
use of his right arm yet he went
onto become an American master.
So all these people had hardships
and difficulties along the
way to get where they got.
And I think that is
such a riveting part
of the research and
part of the story.
And lastly, William Carlos Williams,
and I'll show you a little bit
about how I break open
a book in my art.
So a lot of my books -- a lot
of my art has books in it.
And this is the spine of a
book that I've taken apart.
The cover which I painted on and
then I placed it on the background.
And much of my work
can be seen as a grid.
So the grid is what
I hang my art on.
Like a scaffolding or a skeleton.
Design is not just
about making things.
It's about making things happen
and this was absolutely a series
of teamwork between
Houghton Mifflin and myself.
I do things -- give myself
assignments and made a timeline.
I made a family tree
using a real tree.
Why not? Just pull a tree out
of the ground and we use it.
I had the pleasure of -- as
I said of visiting the farm
and I mapped the farm to give
myself a sense of where he lived
and also looking ways to tell the
story with maps and so I don't have
to say he went cross
country after Cornell.
I can show where he went
and what happened to.
If there was one object,
though, I found was --
represented E.B. White was
the essence of his work,
it was the typewriter but do kids
know what a manual typewriter is?
We put directions at the beginning.
And I used the manual typewriter
in these chapter openers.
This is an example of
an early chapter opener
where there's a typewriter
key and E.B. White's quotes.
And then at the bottom is a label.
So also using office supplies like
he might have had at The New Yorker.
E.B. White wrote so many
essays and beautiful letters.
And as the research went on,
I wanted to use those
quotes within the book.
So I typed them up on a
manual typewriter and there --
I consider these a
hinge into his writing.
My text goes along and then you come
to one of his quotes which furthers
who he was a writer
and part of his life.
Young scholars also want to know
how do I make those big collages
and how do they get in the book?
Well I start with a form.
And I do a lot of sketching.
And you'll see a little bit here
how I created one particular collage
for the Stuart Little page.
And I'm doing a lot of sketches.
And I'm trying to make that
scene where he drives his car
and he ends up at a general store.
And my husband said -- I wanted
to create this scene of a porch.
And I said should I make
a porch out of wood.
I don't know how to do this.
And he said no, just give it
porchness and it'll work fine.
So I'm making all these pieces that
are going to go into the collage.
And again you can see
I'm taking apart a book
and I'm faking a book that's
going to go into the collage.
There are dozens of
things that don't get used.
I've made but I've made Stuart
Little's wonderful birch bark canoe.
I've made his bed made
out of clothes pins.
So just like when you're a
kid and you're playing dolls
and you're making all this stuff, I
think that just never ended for me.
I'm just continuing to
make these collages.
These assemblages.
So I think we don't have time to
see this whole thing but it ends
up looking a bit like this.
You'll see in a second.
I think. There.
So that's the end -- the finished
collage after much pushing
around and pulling around.
He worked for The New Yorker.
Some surprises in that research were
that he shared an office
with James Thurber.
And the two of them, James Thurber
who would become a famous
humorist and cartoonist.
Thurber was as gregarious
as White was reserved.
And he also at The New
Yorker met his future wife,
Katharine Sergeant Angell.
Katharine Angell was
a fiction editor.
They fell in love and married.
She's also the mother
of Arthur Roger Angell.
One of the things I love most
in E.B. White's writing
is The Elements of Style.
That book came to him when
-- as when he was Cornell.
Written by William Strunk.
We think of it now as Strunk and
White because years later, in the --
later in his life, he
edited and revised it.
So Elements of Style
became Strunk and White.
Strunk and White's
Elements of Style.
Katharine and E.B. White spent
the latter part of the years
at their farm in Maine and that's
where he conceived the
story for Charlotte's Web.
I'm not sure we're going to have
time to tell that whole story
but in essence, there
was a sick pig.
And the pig sadly died.
They tried their --
he tried his best
to save the pig's life but he died.
And he said I knelt.
I saw the pig was dead
and left him there.
His face a mild look
expressive neither
of deep peace nor deep suffering
although I think he had suffered a
great deal.
He buried the pig and
later said that I wanted
to find a way to save a pig's life.
A while later he saw a
spider spinning a web
in the door yard of the barn.
And he took that nest
-- sorry I said a web.
I meant a nest.
So she had laid her egg sack.
He took it back to New York.
The eggs hatched.
All these little spiders
were all over his dresser.
He discovered that the
spiders were aranea cavtica
and that he spent the next couple
of years researchign spiders.
So he these two very
divergent episodes.
Later, he was taken some slops
to the barn and he thought what
if a spider could save a pig's life.
He wrote his editor,
Ursula Nordstrom,
has there ever been a spider as a
main character in a children's book?
Not as far as she knew
not since Ms. Muffett.
[Chuckling] So the story of
Charlotte's Web was born.
He was illustrated by Garth
Williams who struggled
with anthropomorphizing Charlotte
and giving her a spider's face.
E.B. White ended up accepting
the more scientific rendition
of Charlotte and at the end, E.B.
White added three hairs and two eyes
to Charlotte and Charlotte was born.
There were many first drafts.
He started off I shall -- he
started off the book with Charlotte.
Charlotte was a big, gray spider
living in the door yard of a barn
but then he changed
to Wilbur, the pig.
I shall speak first of Wilbur.
Another draft completely --
started completely with the barn
and all the animals in it.
And then he switched to the humans.
John Arable went out to the
barn with a lit lantern.
Finally setting the book aside, he
decided to start the book with Fern,
the little girl, and he
-- it's the last line,
this penultimate last line
was where's Papa going
with that hand axe?
Editing it down to where's
Papa going with that axe?
So I love showing these
five drafts in the book
because it shows how he worked the
way many of us work with editing.
He was a consummate
editor and reviser.
He said Charlotte's Web is about
friendship, life, and death.
Stuart Little was about
the quest for beauty.
And Trumpet of the Swan was a
love story not just between Louie,
the swan, and his wife, Serena,
but between father and son.
So E.B. White's work is so
accessible and so delightful,
I was such an honor
to create this book
that incorporated a
lot of his writings.
I'll read one quote.
One last quote.
We have time for one last quote.
[ Silence ]
White writes, sailors have an
expression about the weather.
They say the weather
is a great bluffer.
I guess the same can be
true of our human society.
Things could look dark
then a break shows
in the cloud and all is changed.
Sometimes rather suddenly.
It is quite obvious that the human
race has made a queer mess of life
on this planet but as a people, we
probably harbor seeds of goodness
that have lane waiting
for a long time.
Waiting to sprout when
the conditions are right.
Man's curiosity, his
relentless, his inventiveness,
his ingenuity have led
him into deep trouble.
We can only hope this same traits
will enable him to claw his way out.
Hang onto your hat.
Hang onto your hope for
tomorrow is another day.
Thank you.
[ Clapping ]
We might have time for one question.
We -- one or two questions
if anybody has any questions.
I'm happy to answer.
Maybe some of you met E.B.
White in your lifetime.
Any hands up?
No.
[ Silence ]
[ Inaudible ]
What am I working on next?
Wow. That's a great question.
I don't know if this is public.
I think it's fairly public.
I'm working on a picture book
that Kwame Alexander wrote.
So am I lucky?
Yes. Yes completely different
project but I think that's the fun
of writing and illustrating
children's book.
Each book is incredibly different.
So thank you so much.
I'll be here chatting with
people and then signing later.
Thank you.
Have a great day.
[ Clapping ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.